[Music]
a nanny's only duties is to the
children to keep them swaddled in the
safety of her
care with a Fierce and iron will she
would fight and she would
kill if she's poked she'll be
provoked and you just woke up mama
bear n keeps her patience Under Pressure
you'll never stop me nny forceful and
resourceful as can be don't make me
laugh no matter what you might Hur
toward her she keeps the godamn house in
order I'm going to get those kids then
you'll have to go through
me for the sake of a child and give my
life completely for the sake of a child
to Helen Back I go
no I won't Bend and I won't break there
are precious lives at stake with a fire
I face down any
fall for the sake for the sake for the
sake for the sake of a
child what's a nanny she's a nin she's a
nothing I am the protector and no mat
for such a massive private dick massive
you can shut your little trap it's time
for Nanny's final
and a rattle down your throat should do
the trick I knew it it was you all along
you're the killer I'm not just the
killer I'm the father oh that's
right those kids are mine and you can't
stand in the way Over My Dead
Body for the sake of a child give my
life completely your
life to
back for the s for the sake for the sake
for the sake of a
child the grace in your Gaz is B
chilling it's clear you've been serial
killing I did what I had to do and now
I'm about to do it to you see your just
a baby but wiper disposable just like a
diaper they are mine to protect I have
to object it's me that they need they
grew from my
seed till my last breath I take I'll
stay steast for the
take child you never will defeat
me for child to death I D to
go yes I lay my life at stake with this
vow I make I'll die before I ever let
them
know for the
sake for the
sake for the sake for the sake for the
sake
for the sake of a
[Music]
child